Non-Addictive Heroin? ...and 8 Other Medical
Facts
1.
Before aspirin was introduced, people would
chew on the bark of the white willow tree
to reduce fever and inflammation.
White willow contains salicin, a chemical
similar to acetylsalicylic acid found in today’s
aspirin.
In fact, in the early 1800s salicin was used
to make Aspirin.
The tree has anti-inflammatory effects and
although it may be slower acting, the effects
of salicin in white willow are longer lasting
than Aspirin.
Of course, ingesting this bark also has the
negative side effect of giving you a very
upset stomach.
2.
The human eye can detect somewhere between
100K-10 million shades of color.
For reference, HDMI 1.3 supports 30 bits or
1 billion colors, 36 bits or 68 billion colors,
and 48 bits or 281 trillion colors.
(QF 454)
3.
One of the common early uses of Heroin, which
was marketed as non-addictive, was to help
treat people who were addicted to morphine,
even though Heroin ultimately proved to be
more addictive.
When morphine was first isolated from opium
in 1805, one of its early uses was a “non-addictive”
drug to treat people who were addicted to
the less addictive opium.
(QF: 475)
4.
TNT is poisonous and skin exposure will generally
cause irritation and your skin will turn bright
yellow or orange.
Further, if you eat TNT, your pee will turn
red and look like blood, though it is not.
In fact, during WWI, munitions workers who
handled TNT were called “canary girls”
or “canaries” because their skin that
was exposed to the TNT turned the aforementioned
colors.
On the more serious side, prolonged exposure
to TNT causes liver, blood, spleen, and immune
system problems among others.
5.
Human sperm cells on average tend to be able
to travel about 7 to 8 inches per hour (about
17-20 cm/hr).
(Fact 502)
6.
The reason you can see eye floaters better
when looking at, for instance, a bright blue
sky, is because your pupils contract to a
very small size, thus reducing the aperture,
which in turn makes floaters more apparent
and focused.
7.
Humans enjoy five or more different tastes
namely: sour, bitter, salty, umami (associated
with meat), and sweet.
We can taste sweet things thanks to two proteins
generated by two separate genes.
Cats, on the other hand, have a mutant chemoreceptor
in their taste buds that prevents them from
tasting sweet things, which is actually a
trait shared by all cats big and small, not
just domestic ones.
8.
Another word for growling “tummy” sounds
is “borborygmi”.
(Fact 484)
9.
Opiorphin is a chemical in human saliva that,
according to Dr. C Rougeot et al in a 2010
study, is 6 times more potent than morphine,
gram for gram.
(QF 509)